all right we got clear skies out there
and it is crisp this morning everybody
we've got 30s spring valley 39
centennial hills below freezing up at
kyle canyon
sky canyon at 37 so yeah definitely
around the edges of the valley it is
super cool
north las vegas you're at 44. 46 at
whitney ranch 37
right now in the south end of the valley
at anthem so we still have some wind
going
and where we have the wind advisories is
right along the river again
national weather service decided to
reissue that for today look at red rock
28
not much wind out there in the valleys
down to freezing
so yesterday 65 for our first day of
december was beautiful
today a little bit cooler with these
northeast breezes they'll get up to
about 15 maybe 20 miles an hour this
afternoon in the valley
but just about double that maybe up to
30 35 40 miles an hour along the river
and we've already had gusts
to 40 plus down at catherine's landing
overnight
sunrise at 6 34 4 26 is the sunset
we're staying very dry these
northeasterly breezes are super dry
so please keep yourself hydrated and
keep drinking lots of water big water
bottle with you today
lots of snow remember we've seen all
that lake effect snow
that's all swirling east now through
upper new england today
it will eventually make its way off the
coast so the wind advisory
is 8 a.m to 8 p.m for the lake in the
river areas today
and we're looking at cooler temps 60
today down to 57 tomorrow
59 is normal so really right in the
ballpark where we should be
but we've got a warmer weekend back to
mid 60s even mid to
upper 60s super mild next week